[Música]
y
te has puesto a pensar lo que pierdes
por utilizar efectivo por los últimos 4
años de mi vida me he concentrado en
encontrar las experiencias las mejores
experiencias en finanzas y ver cómo la
tecnología las ha revolucionado y puedo
visitar lugares donde el efectivo ya es
casi nulo y puedo platicar con las
personas que hicieron esta revolución y
estoy convencido que todos nosotros como
personas sociedad y hasta el gobierno
nos podemos beneficiar de un méxico sin
efectivo
yo nací y crecí con la revolución más
grande que tiene la tecnología y me
encanta me encanta explicarlo con algo
que para todos a sonar muy simple pero
que para mí creciendo fue súper súper
importante la tarea
para mí la tarea cuando fui creciendo
era súper importante era lo único que yo
tenía que hacer para tener estos pasos
felices y para recibir todo lo que yo
quería y como muchos de ustedes siempre
siendo la tarea con esto
con las monografías
mientras fue pasando el tiempo y
mientras yo crecía y demás también la
tecnología fue creciendo conmigo
recuerdo muy bien cuando empecé a
utilizar la enciclopedia britannica
recuerdo perfecto perfecto perfecto en
carta 95 por qué porque cuarto de
primaria para mí fue el año el mejor año
que me fuerza que pudo 10 gracias en
carta y después de eso llegó el internet
el internet que al principio no sabíamos
si la información era verdadera si no
era verdadera
pero después ahorita ya tenemos toda esa
información al alcance de nuestros dedos
simplemente en wikipedia tiene más de 40
millones de artículos imagínense toda
esa información pero no solamente la
tecnología ha revolucionado la forma en
que tenemos información o en la que yo
hago la tarea también ha revolucionado
todo nuestro día
ha transformado la forma en que nos
comunicamos la forma en que compramos
cosas inclusive la forma en que ligamos
pero algo que no ha tocado la tecnología
ha sido el efectivo y la manera en que
entre nosotros transacción amos
este ha sido lo que yo he visto de
cambios en mi vida que ver con cómo me
relaciono con las personas en efectivo
he visto cambios de colores también
eliminaciones evaluaciones por supuesto
pero al final del día cuando quiero
transaccionar con alguien en el día a
día sigo dependiendo de algo siga donde
papel y de moneda esta forma de
transaccionar lleva más de tres mil años
yo propongo que es hora de cambiar lo
que es hora de que encontremos una forma
más fácil y más amigable para poder
hacer todo esto me van a preguntar
ok martín perfecto cuál es esa cosa tan
innovadora y tan tecnológica que nos vas
a presentar eso no es de innovadora ni
nada que ver de hecho estoy seguro que
todos ustedes aquí los mayores de 18
años mínimo ya son parte de esto y es el
sistema bancario
van a decir meta martín en el banco es
lo que ves es tu gran innovación si por
ahorita yo no creo que sea lo mejor pero
por ahorita es lo mejor que tenemos
existen las cripto monedas existe el
block change sin lugar a dudas pero por
ahorita todavía no llegamos ahí somos
más de 50 millones de mexicanos que ya
estamos en el sistema bancario personas
más de 120 millones hay mucho que se
puede hacer y sobre todo cada 10 más
fácil unirnos a esto tratar de
convenceros un poquito más acerca de
esto les dar tres puntos del por qué el
dinero digital es mucho mejor que
cualquier efectivo y el primero es que
el efectivo es caro para todos nosotros
qué me refiero con claro saben ustedes
que los mexicanos gastamos 2.3 billones
billones con b de pesos y 48 millones de
horas solamente en conseguir efectivo no
me refiero a trabajar por él ni nada así
simplemente en trasladarnos a
conseguirlo vamos hace unos poquitos de
números eso es lo que a mí me cuesta
conseguir efectivo cada vez que lo
necesito me tengo que parar de mi
asiento sacar mi carro manejar pagar
estacionamiento gastar en gasolina
en total ahí me cuesta el reloj de 40
pesos y me toma casi 30 minutos hacerlo
si esto lo comparo con alguien muy
cercana a mí mi abuela es completamente
diferente
ella vive en un pueblo de sinaloa y para
conseguir efectivo lo que ella tiene que
hacer es salir de su casa agarrar un
camión que le cuesta 70 pesos 35 día 35
de vuelta y todo este le cuesta más de
100 pesos y le toma más de 4 horas
sin lugar a dudas el efectivo nos afecta
en nuestra productividad y en nuestra
cartera pero no solamente eso si nos
vamos un poquito más allá y nos ponemos
en la parte del gobierno el gobierno el
costo que tiene el gobierno del efectivo
en méxico es enorme tenemos un país muy
vasto
y compuesto que ellos tienen que hacer
no solamente en crear la moneda o crear
el billete pero sino también
transportaron los lugares eso es un
gasto superfluo si nos ponemos a ver si
lo ponemos en números se estima que del
que de lo social el dinero que le mandan
a las personas solamente les llega el
40% el otro 60 son gastos de logística y
de envío de dinero
como un ejemplo un programa como
progresa gasta más de 22 millones de
pesos en ligas en ligas para amarrar el
efectivo en un mundo sin efectivo esto
no sucedería yo no tendría por qué ir al
cajero yo no tendría por qué gastar
tiempo y hacer filas para conseguir algo
que es mío yo tendría el acceso directo
24/7 lo podría gastar como yo quisiera
al igual que mi abuela
como segundo punto en nuestra forma de
verlo el efecto es inconveniente e
inhibe la competitividad a quienes le ha
pasado que de repente quiere comprar
algo
y se dan cuenta que no traen efectivo
a todos yo creo que pasa nos vamos
primero y vamos caminando al oxxo más
cercano y ahí lo compramos con tarjeta
que es lo que pasa está matando esta
forma de no aceptar la aceptación de
pagos está matando a todas las pequeños
comercios que nosotros conocíamos y ese
es el caso de víctor víctor tiene una
tiendita en la plana con temas de la
ciudad e méxico que está muy cerca de
nuestra oficina y él heredó esta tienda
en los años 90 y fue creciendo es un
poquito más grande tenía más producto
estuviera muy bien empezó a salir
competencia alrededor pero no importaba
tanto en una competencia legal hasta que
en el año en los años 2000 es le
pusieron esto en la esquina
o no en ese momento a él se le vino
abajo todo dijo no lo sé puede ser
muchas más cosas que yo yo no puedo
competir con ellos ni impresión y mucho
mejor y mucho más importante yo no puedo
competir con ellos en aceptación de
pagos nosotros nos dimos cuenta de esto
porque víctor llegó con nosotros un día
y no se nos veía pasar por su tienda y
regresábamos con la bolsa de oxxo no
todos todo todo toda la chavista y una
vez nos agarró nos preguntó chavos
porque iban hasta allá si les quedó más
cerca y usted y por qué no me compran a
mí que estoy más sé por qué lo hacen
ganaste el oxxo la respuesta muy simple
víctor aceptas tarjeta no es ahí
nosotros trabajamos con él para
conseguirle una opción para que él
pudiera empezar a aceptar pagos
electrónicos trabajamos con él para
entender el por qué nunca había aceptado
pagos electrónicos y que le daba miedo
de eso nos dimos cuenta de dos cosas muy
simples la primera era que él sentía que
las comisiones se las estaban robando de
sus ganancias y la segunda y muy
importante nos está bancarizado a partir
de allí cuando trabajamos con él y lo
ayudamos en esto nos dimos cuenta que él
quien avanzó mucho más no solamente
aceptaba pagos electrónicos lo cual para
él era siete mil pesos mensuales más de
lo que ganaba antes sino que también ya
pudo sacar su primer préstamo esto es
súper importante un mundo bancarizado un
mexico bancarizado significa que todos
tenemos las mismas oportunidades que
todos podemos tener acceso a préstamos
de toda la educación financiera
es por eso que para mí el efectivo cero
digital 2
tercero el efectivo impide la
transferencia y es una de las mayores
razones de la corrupción
el gobierno desde el más más más
concentrado en erradicar el efectivo
dentro de nosotros
por qué
si tú sacas por cada 1% que sacas de la
economía informal y lo vuelves formal el
ingreso al erario público incrementa más
de 10 mil millones de pesos
esto significa que la cantidad que
podría tener el gobierno para gastar
para el bien social incrementaría
muchísimo ya sé lo que me van a decir
oye martín porque el chiste es no darle
más y no al gobierno
el chiste se lo van a robar no sabemos
no pero así como el gobierno va a tener
mucha más visibilidad hacia nosotros
nosotros podemos tener visibilidad es el
gobierno el dieron no se pierde cuando
es digital el dinero se pierde en el
momento en que se vuelve físico de igual
manera se estima que se desvían diarios
110 millones de pesos del gobierno o sea
40 mil millones de pesos se desvían a
base del efectivo si nosotros pudiéramos
saber que todo este dinero que vamos a
pagar en impuestos lo vamos a ver
reflejado en nuestras vidas yo creo que
todos nosotros teníamos está bien lo
pagó y no hay problema
es por eso que el efectivo 0 y digital 3
en el mundo ya existen todas estas ideas
todos somos parte de un ecosistema
fintech existen países primermundistas
como lo es estados unidos europa pero
también lo existe en economías en
desarrollo como la es nigeria y como lo
es india y en méxico ya estamos llegando
ahí actualmente todos nosotros juntos
con muchas más empresas y muchas más
tecnologías somos parte del fin de que
el fintech es una revolución que está
sucediendo en el ecosistema financiero y
sobre todo aquí en méxico tenemos la
tormenta perfecta para que pase existe
la necesidad el mercado las
oportunidades y ahorita sobre todo la
regulación somos el país que esto pasó
el día de ayer que porque somos el
primer país en que tenemos una
regulación para la csf intex esto no
solamente los protegió ustedes como
susana como a nosotros como usuarios
pero también nos da a nosotros como
emprendedores la libertad y la seguridad
que vamos a poder seguir haciendo esto
por mucho más tiempo
me van a preguntar perfecto martín listo
todo está muy simple parece ser que es
muy fácil porque todo no estamos en ese
momento porque todavía estamos
dependiendo del efectivo en nuestro día
a día hay muchas cosas que hacer
muchísimas y todos tenemos algo que
hacer ahí primero que nada el gobierno
el gobierno está haciendo muy cosas muy
buenas la ley sinde que es algo que
todos necesitábamos en este mundo y
ustedes como usuario estoy seguro que
pronto van a empezar a ver cosas muy muy
importantes que les van a hacer la vida
mucho más fácil pero se necesita más se
necesita incentivos del gobierno para
que esto pase en india está pasando en
india quitaron un billete el billete de
mayor circulación lo sacaron del mercado
todo para incentivar que las personas se
metieran al mundo
al mundo digital y pudieran interactuar
de manera más fácil
a todos los emprendedores que me están
escuchando hay mucho todavía por hacer
concéntrense en el problema que quieren
hacer y escuchen a sus usuarios esto
hará que los usuarios sepan que nosotros
sepamos lo que los usuarios quieren y
quiénes podamos solucionar la vida a
todos los comerciantes de algún
comerciante aquí que no está aceptando
efectivo digo que nos aceptando pagos
digitales que sólo acepta efectivo yo
los invito a que lo acepten yo les
aseguro que verán cómo cómo sus ingresos
se incrementarán y recuerden que si
empresas en el banco valen igualito que
si empresas en la bolsa y a todos
nosotros como sociedad nosotros somos la
parte más importante de toda esta
ecuación yo los invito a que prueben
otras más de 80 empresas en méxico que
estamos tratando de hacerle la vida más
fácil a todos ustedes muchos de nosotros
tratando en efectivo pero también para
el ahorro simplemente para que toda
nuestra vida sea mucho más fácil
los invito que se vuelvan embajadores
los invito a que lo prueben y si les
gusta vayan con otras personas que les
seguimos a nuestros hijos de nuestros
pequeños hermanos oprimidos como se
utiliza el dinero digital y que no le
tengamos miedo a este sé que es una
novedosa dice que muchos van a decir que
es imposible sé que los retractores y
que será una pesquisa largos o pues es
un largo y bastante difícil de obtener
pero también sé que aquí me están
escuchando y me están viendo los early
adopters las personas que en verdad
quieren hacer una diferencia por eso los
invito a que se unan a esta revolución
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]